in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadium for September 14 on which we commemorate the exaltation
of the precious and life-giving cross.
On the 14th of the month we celebrate the feast of the universal exaltation of the precious
and life-giving cross.
Saint Constantine the Great, commemorated on the 21st of May, was preparing to march on Rome
to confront his rival, Maxentias, when the sign of the life-giving cross appeared
to him in the midday sky, surrounded with the inscription, by this sign, you shall conquer.
He therefore had his standards adorned with the sign of the cross and won a brilliant victory
that enabled him to assume power over the entire Roman world and to assure the triumph
of Christianity.
In the 20th year of his reign, in the year 326, Constantine sent his mother St. Helen to
Jerusalem to venerate the holy places and to find the site of the Holy Sepulchre and of
the cross that was covered by rubble from building works done at the time of Hadrian when the
city had been enlarged.
Relying upon the oral tradition of the faithful, St. Helen found the precious trophy along
with the crosses on which the two thieves had hung, and the three nails that had nailed
the life-giving body of the Savior.
But she could see no way of telling which was the cross of Christ.
The healing of a dying woman at the touch of the Holy Wood enabled Macardios, the patriarch
of Jerusalem, to identify the cross of Christ.
For no miracle was worked by the other two crosses.
Then the queen and her whole court worshipped the Holy Cross and kissed it with great devotion.
The people who had gathered in large numbers at the place also wanted to share in this grace
or at least so ardent was their love for Christ to see from afar the instrument of our redemption.
So the patriarch mounted the ambo and taking the cross in both hands raised it on high so
that all could see it while the crowd exclaimed, Kirie Eleison.
This was the occasion of the institution and all the churches of the exaltation of the
precious cross, not only in memory of the event, but also to show forth this instrument
of shame as having become our pride and our joy.
By recalling the action of the patriarch and by elevating the cross at the four points
of the compass to the chant of Kirie Eleison, Christians show today that in mounting the
cross Christ desired to reconcile all things to himself, uniting creation in all its height
and depth and to its farthest bounds in his body so that we may have access through him to the Father.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us and save us.